you like issues in serious substance as
we talk about it but this there is
pageantry have you feel about that well
my speech was not Patrick true yeah and
the reason as I understand that we have
brought out what people to the soapbox
than any other candidate is precisely
because we are talking about real issues
and what real issues are is the fact
that the middle class of America is
disappearing we have the highest rate of
childhood poverty of any major country
and almost all of the new income and
wealth is going to the top 1% that is a
real issue a real issue is that our
campaign finance system and let me
underline the word don't miss hope the
others it is a corrupt system the United
spanker up it is probably the corrupt
people the Supreme Court the game of
citizens united created a system in
which billionaires can buy elections the
United States can no longer go around
the world and lecture countries on
democracy when what our country is
becoming is a system in which
billionaires can spend unlimited sums of
money to electric and electronic say ye
sword corruption yeah who's corrupted
alien ears does still in mono this is a
system that not only other people look
they'll obeying the law the Koch
brothers are going to spend more money
than the Democrats and Republicans is
that illegal no Supreme Court said they
can do that i'm talking about a corrupt
system it is it an instance of
corruption if one of your rivals or any
of your rivals has a super PAC that
accepts money from billionaires I think
the whole entire system is corrupt I
don't know I think I maybe I'm not sure
the only candidate that doesn't have a
super PAC and we are gonna try let me
tell you it ain't easy presumably but if
it presumably if the system is corrupt
there's a corruption there if a
candidate for president Republican or
Democrat is taking unlimited donations
from billionaires that would seem to be
the perfect example of what you're
talking about that would seem to be a
corrupt no but corrupt know the system
is corrupt and where people will tell
you hey the system allows me to do that
I will do that they're not breaking the
law super PAC is what the law says what
I am talking about is and I think you
are saying by the way across the
political spectrum not just progresses
concern
are saying what sense does it make when
one family an extreme right-wing Koch
family can spend more money than either
the democratic or republican parties and
what the media I think has got to do is
find these all the spate of a deal that
is not democracy that is called
oligarchy where you have a nation in
which a handful of billionaires control
the political possibly true for Toms
fire and george soros yes it's true for
any billionaire all right but clearly in
this election most of the money is gonna
come from Republicans but our the idea
that any billionaire can have this
outsized influence makes no sense at all
to me i was saying right next to you
there while you were giving that speech
you got a yellow piece of paper in your
here which you never looked at but you
kept holding on to what's on that paper
top secret i can't tell you can email
FBI university alan you spend the last
week you're out on the west coast and a
huge crowds tens of thousands of people
right get here you're just a boon this
morning just a few hundred people know
that'll let them are you kidding me
boone iowa we had six hundred people
does anybody know the population of
boone iowa that's a good point of Budo
that's a great plan these people not
heard you want your monster imitation
can you get